eric is with us in orlando hi eric
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi mr ramsey how are you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
so i got a lawsuit from my credit card
for non-payments and i spoke to a lawyer
who advised that i filed for bankruptcy
and i wasn't sure if that's a bankruptcy
lawyer
yes yeah well asking a bankruptcy lawyer
if you're bankrupt it's like asking a
dog if it's hungry
yeah how much is the lawsuit eric
uh 12 000. what do you make
less than ten thousand why
i'm working two part-time jobs one's
like
eight dollars an hour and the other's
twelve dollars an hour you're not
working on much
yeah how do you er thirty-one
yeah what's wrong what's wrong yeah and
what's what's happening with you brother
it sounds like you've been kicked around
um
how come you don't have a full-time job
eric
well after college i applied but i
didn't have any help
and with the i lost my last job with the
pandemic
okay what was your last job sir i was
busting tables at olive garden
okay and you're 31 yes
what did you go to school for creative
writing
okay and uh do you do you live with your
mom and dad
no i love live with roommates here in
florida okay
all right um and you have twelve
thousand dollars in
on a credit card how much other debt do
you have sir
uh including the twelve thousand dollars
it's twenty thousand dollars
in um debt what is the other eight
um mostly medical bills okay what kind
of medical problems have you had
um
nothing major i just hadn't like er
visits
okay all right um
okay let me tell you what i'm hearing
and you tell me you
you tell me if i'm wrong okay okay
um i hear that you have a pretty extreme
income problem
and meaning you don't make any money at
all hardly
uh and that's not a put down it's just
where you are right now
and meaning that that is more of a
problem than the debt is
in other words if we could
double your income today
i can't but let's just pretend i could
wave a one and double your income
then we could address this debt very
quickly because you figured out a way to
make it on nothing you figured out a way
to make it on ten thousand dollars
and if you had another ten thousand
dollars a year coming in you'd be able
to pay this off real quickly couldn't
you
yes okay and you're living below the
poverty level
and so income is our question what do
you feel like is holding you back
on your career
i'm just trying to get my foot in the
door i suppose
okay all right i tell you what i don't
think you're bankrupt
right i think you have a career crisis
yeah
and the credit card company even if they
sued you there's not anything they can
get
because you don't have an income that
they can get a hold of
and you don't have anything in your bank
account that they can get a hold of and
you don't have any assets
and so you're what we in that world call
judgment proof
and so sir i think what you have more
than anything else is i think we've got
to do
something to get your career going and
get your income up
and so uh if you do that i think
very very very quickly uh you would be
able to
solve this this problem do you have a
car
yes i do okay what year is it man
uh 2004 okay i think i would be
delivering pizzas five nights a week or
six nights a week if i were you
if you were doing that the people that
we work with around the country that
we're doing that are making
fifteen hundred dollars a month which is
eighteen thousand dollars a year if you
did that on top
of your income now that would almost
triple your income and you'd be able to
dramatically the bad dramatically impact
this the bad news is you don't make much
money the good news is
a little bit of a move will greatly
impact your situation
and so we've got to get working on the
income side of your equation
because even if we waived one and you
had no debt today
you've still got a mess because of your
income would you agree with me on that
yes okay uh eric you're in orlando
florida and you have
a very reliable car any reason why you
haven't tried uber because you know the
average uber is making in between six to
twelve hundred dollars a week
so have you tried that
especially with orlando being a very
busy city and they're they're open
um that's something i could look forward
to
look into currently i'm working two jobs
and i've been getting like um i'm doing
15 hour days working almost
over 50 hours but you're making it yeah
but you're not making any money
so it might be that one of those jobs
needs to trade out for a better job
absolutely or both of them need to trade
out for better jobs
i'm not sure so here's what we're going
to do we're going to help you okay
number one i'm going to put you into
ramsey plus
for a year which includes all of the
financial peace university and the every
dollar budgeting app to help you with
your money
but that's not your issue number two i'm
going to connect you up with ken coleman
and um kelly just have
ken call eric offline and and
and give him uh 20 minutes as a favor to
me
ken eric is our our career specialist
here is the ken coleman show it's on 65
radio stations around america
and he helps people with their careers
yeah
and um and i'm also going to send you
his book to read
the proximity principle and see if we
can't help you
do something in the it could be in the
vo tech world it doesn't have to be
fancy
and it doesn't have to be that you get a
phd in a degree to go do something
we've just got to get you thinking
differently about your income side
because i think honey that's where
you're struggling yeah matter of fact i
know that's where you're struggling
and um uh so you could file bankruptcy
if you want to
but it's not going to solve your problem
and you will regret it down the road and
you'll still be right back there
yeah in no time because you don't have
an income yeah
and that's what's going to get you